the walls are closing in on President
Trump if you believe the mainstream
media but as Trump's opponents are
threatening impeachment we examine the
bigger picture President Trump may just
be the worst public servant in the
United States
except for all the others then
Democratic presidential candidate Tulsi
Gabbard rhetorically grinds Hillary
Clinton into a mound of dust the left
celebrates menstruation okay and Amy
Klobuchar and the moderates see they're
opening all that and more I'm Michal
Knowles and this is the Michael Hill
show the walls are closing in and when
the walls are closing in on you it's
very important to be prepared in the
case of an emergency how good was that
segue that's why we need to thank our
friends over at wise company wise
company takes an innovative approach on
providing dependable simple and
affordable freeze-dried food the thing I
love about wise company is I'm a man I
don't really think of everything I'm not
all that organized I've just got this
kind of low level of stress where I
think if we got to get out of Dodge if
something really bad happens natural
disaster I live pretty much right on a
fault line or a political disaster we
see political disasters all around us
every day if something happens I want to
make sure that my family is safe and so
what you do with wise company you just
order the food you get excellent really
really high quality food that will last
you in an emergency and then you just
put it away and you don't think about it
and then that stress is gone you don't
need to worry about sweet little Alisa
and the zombie apocalypse you cannot
know what tomorrow may bring but you can
have peace of mind knowing that you will
be ready for it
when government resources are strained
you can't depend on nobody you got to
depend on your self this week my
listeners can get any wise emergency or
at door food product and an extra 25%
off the lowest marked price you can do
that by going to wise food storage comm
and to enter Noel's kayano wles
at checkout you can also call eight five
five four five three twenty nine
forty-five and tell us that we sent you
plus shipping is free wise has a 90 day
no questions asked
return policy now I don't think the
Armageddon is going to happen within 90
days but they do have this great return
policy so there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get yourself and your
family more prepared today it is just a
great investment not only in your family
not only in the future it's a great
investment in your peace of mind do it
go to wise food storage Comm promo code
Knowles Kino wles to get any wise
emergency or at door food product at an
extra 25% off plus free shipping but the
walls are already closing in on
president from Fox News's Chris Wallace
says there is now a 20% chance that the
Senate GOP will vote to remove President
Trump from office so that's not just
impeachment there's two steps to this
right there's an impeachment which is if
the house votes to impeach him you know
like happened to Bill Clinton and then
there is the trial and the Senate so
once you're impeached you go to trial in
the Senate and the Senate can vote
either to remove you from office or not
to remove you from office what we've
always assumed is that the house is
going to move forward with impeachment
they'll probably impeach the guy but
it'll get to the Senate and there's no
way that he's gonna get impeached in the
Senate why not well because Republicans
still control the Senate so if
Republicans control the Senate he's
probably not getting convicted
furthermore there doesn't seem to be any
real legal basis for impeachment there
doesn't seem to be anything that he's
done that rises to the level of high
crimes and misdemeanors but third and
this has been most important so far even
among Democrats support for removal from
office
nationally according to one poll is only
66% so that's he that's even Democrats
that means that if there were no
Republicans in the country if the whole
Senate were controlled by Democrats they
still would not remove him from office
because support nationally is only at
66% now we're hearing that that is not
the case Chris Wallace is saying that
his highly-placed sources in Washington
believe that there is a one in five
chance that the Senate run by
Republicans remove strum from office
there is seems to be a growing number of
Republicans in Congress who are if not
breaking with the president distancing
themselves from the president and I
talked to a very well-connected
Republican in Washington this week
somebody whose name you wouldn't know
well whose
that if the House votes to impeach and
it gets to a trial in the Senate there
is now a 20% chance he believes
obviously it's just an estimate now a
20% chance enough Republicans will vote
with the Democrats to remove the
president oh that that that that's just
absurd but let's deal with the issue of
Syria with no let's deal with the issue
of whether Republicans you're losing
your support that's the same thing as
this that's comment about the 20%
chances just that the person clearly
doesn't know what they're talking about
well hold on what about chris wallace is
very highly placed source okay i don't
want to name any names but it rhymes
with quill pistol okay and he knows that
it's a one in five chance the trim quits
removed her ID not naming any names but
it might run with backs moot okay i'm
talking about republicans who hate
trump's guts so so i don't know i mean
maybe there is there are a lot of
republicans who hate trump's guts maybe
there's a chance that they remove him
from office as for specific senators
mitt romney who a lot of us forgot was a
senator because he was a governor a
million years ago and then he was a
twice failed presidential candidate Mitt
Romney is now a senator and he is
signaling that he might vote to remove
Trump from office and this gets to my
big point today which is on how
absolutely terrible and awful and the
worst guy in the world Trump is except
for all of his critics Mitt Romney wants
to remove Trump from office that's the
big headline that's on all the big news
sites that's not news Mitt Romney has
always wanted to remove Trump from
office he gave one of the most
hysterical speeches I've ever seen in
politics before the 2016 election
telling Republicans not to vote for
Trump and more or less to let Hillary
Clinton win he is constantly campaigning
against president drum there's nothing
new about it
same with the DC establishment the
highly placed Republican Chris Wallace
talks to says he really hates Trump yeah
you don't say well I'm shocked to hear
that so now they're gonna remove him
from office over a phone call with
Ukraine or something like that what are
the odds that this actually happens no
matter what you think of Donald Trump I
understand there are a lot of people who
hate his guts just looking at the
likelihood of removal from office the
mainstream media have been predicting
that this
guy will get thrown out of office every
day since he was elected first he was
gonna be removed from office because of
Russia the walls are closing in you
remember every mainstream media guy said
the walls are closing in ad nauseam for
two and a half years and it was stormy
Daniels because apparently it's a high
crime and misdemeanor to get a little
beard with a pornstar before you're ever
running for office then it was the taxes
he you didn't pay his taxes you remember
that the mainstream media said he never
paid taxes for 18 years and then my
doppelganger over at MSNBC actually got
his tax returns it turns out he had paid
a higher tax rate than Bernie Sanders or
Barack Obama or at least paid
significantly more in taxes and then now
it's Ukraine is this actually going to
remove him from office that raises the
two conflicting points about the Trump
era Trump has a lot of vulnerabilities
he's lived a very colorful life he's
done a lot of things that are not
something people are very proud of he's
done a lot of things that bring a lot of
shame to a lot of people opens him up to
a lot of political attacks the other
vulnerability he is generally unfamiliar
with the machinery of government this is
partly why he was elected because he's
not a career politician he hasn't been
in Washington his whole life the trouble
with that is he has struggled
significantly on the legislative front
and he's walked into traps that swamp
eager creatures would have otherwise
avoided I mean even just on the
legislative front
he nearly repealed Obamacare and then he
couldn't wrangle the Senators one
senator in particular he sometimes just
walks into these traps that guys who
have been in DC for a long time wouldn't
do that and then there's the big
vulnerability the big vulnerability is
actually his biggest pitch to voters
which is that he's a successful
businessman he is a successful now I
know that sounds like it's all plus and
there's no downside there is a gunsight
because specifically Trump is the owner
of a business that was built around his
personality and the same people who
clamor for a we need a businessman for
president are the same people who
criticize what happens when we have a
businessman as president conservatives
always talk about that we need a guy to
run this country like a business deal ok
you got him mrs. Trump Trump is the
businessman president okay and and the
knock on him is that he is gonna benefit
from the office yeah I guess he would
everybody benefits from the office
whether you whether people are more
interested in staying your real estate
properties or you get two hundred
thousand dollars speaking fees after you
leave office everybody benefits in some
way the way that Trump is going to
benefit is he has a business called the
Trump Organization so he could never put
that into a blind trust right he could
never totally divorce himself from that
business because he is the business he's
the product he is essentially a show
business figure and in show business you
are the product but everything else I
mean in real estate he just licenses his
name to a lot of buildings in casinos he
licenses his name to them in neckties
that are produced in China he licenses
his name so you can't ever have Donald
Trump step away from the Trump
Organization and there's no such thing
as the Trump Organization it's the same
thing we saw at the g7 for this g7
summit that's coming up Trump wanted to
host it at his Trump Doral property and
people threw a hissy fit about him
the reason they threw a hissy fit is
because they don't want the president
profiting actually funneling taxpayer
money into his own pockets of course we
all agree with that that would be a
terrible thing the president would have
to make sure if he hosts the g7 summit
at his own property that he doesn't make
any money on it the way he was going to
do this was by paying for the whole
thing himself by not charging anybody a
single penny and then there's no sign of
impropriety but that apparently violates
the law he's not allowed to do this he
has to charge a base cost so then he
said okay I'll do it it cost and then
you get the same attack which is well
he's going to be profiting in some way
or another he's gonna be profiting
that's what happens when you elect a
businessman I'm not even advocating
electing a businessman as president I'm
just saying if you want a businessman
that is what you're gonna get and if you
want a career politician you're not
gonna have to deal with those kind of
things but who wants a career politician
the other aspect of the Trump era that
this all raises is Trump has all these
critics right they're all high and
mighty and they know Trump is the worst
guy in the world and he's terrible and
he slept with a porn star he's just a
terrible guy except Trump's critics
aren't any better
in many ways they're much much worse I
specifically want to get to Mitt Romney
but before I have savored few things in
Republican politics more then savaging
Mitt Romney I have been doing this now
for eight years since he ran for
president 2012 so I've I can't wait to
compare Mitt Romney the great the
glorious the virtuous Mitt Romney to
that awful terrible debase Donald Trump
we'll get to that in one second first I
have to thank our friends over at Boland
branch you know how much I love Boland
branch listen I'm on the road right now
okay I'm sleeping at hotels they're not
they're not the highest end hotels I am
missing my bowl and bread sheets like I
can't possibly tell you because on the
rare occasion on the road that I've
gotten to stay at really really nice
hotels
I just thought gosh this luxury is so
great how can I get this in my own home
when I got married I want to register
for different gifts and things like that
turns out luxury sheets can cost like
$1,000 in the store I never knew this
because I was about to $20 cheapo sheets
that feel like sandpaper they can cost a
lot of money unless you go to Boland
branch everything bowline branch makes
is from pure 100% organic cotton
it means they start out super soft they
get even softer over time they are as
good as it gets
there everyone who tries Boleyn branch
loves them that's why I have thousands
of five-star reviews but buying directly
from bolna branch means you cut out the
middleman you're not paying that huge
markup that gets the sheets up to a
thousand bucks with Bolin branching pay
just a couple hundred bucks they feel
incredible trust me you're gonna spend a
third of your life sleeping if you're
like me you're gonna spend two thirds of
your life sleeping you want to make sure
you don't skimp out on that kind of
luxury you can have that luxury at home
you can do it at Bolin Brand shipping is
free you can try them for 30 nights if
you don't love them send them back for a
refund you're not gonna want to send
them back there is no risk no reason not
to give them a try to get started right
now my listeners get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at Boland branch com
promo code Michel mi CH AE L that's Bo
and branch comm for $50 off your first
sheets Bo ll and branch comm promo code
Michael mi CH AE L Boland branch comm
promo code Michael
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney to me is the
Trump Critic par excellence because he's
not just a leftist it's so easy to go
after leftists and they're always gonna
go after you and you're gonna go after
them it's not a big deal but Romney
Romney is different because Romney is a
snake this guy pretends to be mr.
conservative mr. Republican mr.
wonderful virtuous great guy
who does Mitt Romney think he is to
criticize Donald Trump
I'm not saying that Donald Trump is some
beacon of virtue Donald Trump is far
from a beacon of virtue but Mitt Romney
is one of the oiliest
most deceitful least admirable
politicians in recent history he's
simply awful just to remind you in case
you forgot who Mitt Romney is here's
just a little a little retrospective
through the ages of Mitt Romney so when
asked well I preserve and protect a
woman's right to choose I make an
unequivocal answer yes I will preserve
and protect a woman's right to choose
and have devoted and dedicated to
honoring my word in that regard I will
not change any provisions of
Massachusetts's pro-choice laws I was an
independent during the time of Reagan
Bush I'm not trying to return to Reagan
Bush my positions don't talk about
things that you suggest they talk about
well they do they start talking about
those things when you're running in a
different election in 2008 and then you
say you're severely conservative and
you're very pro-life and you're all
these things Mitt Romney has held two
sides of every single issue he has
nothing even vaguely resembling a
vertebrate his jaw is he is just moves
with the wind what good has Mitt Romney
ever done for the conservative movement
nothing what good has Mitt Romney ever
done in public life nothing he invented
Obamacare he assailed the legacy of
Ronald Reagan when he was governor he
wasn't even able to create jobs job
growth was awful in Massachusetts when
he was governor it was one-and-a-half
percent compared to a national average
of 5.3 percent
Massachusetts was 47 47th out of 50
states during Romney's term he then it
passed a bill to force taxpayers to pay
for college for a quarter of
Massachusetts high school graduates
that's that severely conservative MIT
Romney who's just taking taxpayer money
funneling it to children who are
statistically elite and propping up this
educational institution which has done
very little other than indoctrinate
students and leftism for the last five
decades he was anti Second Amendment he
supported the so-called assault weapons
ban tried to take rifles with some of
the most popular guns in America out of
the hands of law-abiding Americans he
was pro-abortion as you saw in that clip
as you heard him say he supported
scientific research on babies who were
killed by a
Horsham the best thing that Mitt Romney
did his governor of Massachusetts was
cut taxes but he didn't even really cut
taxes because he raised fees which are
not only a tax they are there they're a
secret tax there were dishonest tax
they're a way to raise taxes when you
don't want to have to face voters and
say you raise taxes so you raise
so-called fees which are much more
arbitrary and he raised fees more than
any other governor in the country Romney
has absolutely no credibility on this I
can't I can't stand it you know I worked
for two of Mitt Romney's opponents in
the 2012 Republican presidential
primaries so I don't want anybody to
suggest that my attacks on Mitt Romney
are opportunistic now because I like
Trump and he's going after Trump has
nothing to do with that
I've been calling this guy out since I
don't know seven eight years ago and I
think only now are people beginning to
realize it this whole shtick of Saint
mitt the most honorable wonderful guy in
America mr. severely conservative is
total BS and it's fine if you want to
call Trump a BS sir you know he's a New
Yorker he talks that way but MIT Romney
is no better and in many many ways when
you compare his actual policy record he
is so much worse than Trump who for all
his many flaws and he has many many
flaws has actually affected a fairly
relatively conservative administration
now beyond all of that my rant against
Mitt Romney aside President Trump did
get some good news as they're talking
about throwing out of office in the
Senate also in the Senate Lindsey Graham
who was president Trump's biggest critic
on the Syria decision the decision to
remove some troops from northern Syria
which permitted a Turkish invasion which
has hurt our allies in the YPG which is
a group of Kurds that fought alongside
us against Isis Lindsey Graham is
starting to come around on president
Trump's Syria policy areas tell you
where I think we are withhold judgment
as to what's going to happen in Syria
until us all in I am increasingly
optimistic that we can have some
historic solutions in Syria that have
eluded us for years if we play our cards
right I'll blame or the one for the
invasion not
but here's what the president told me
over the weekend here our objectives to
make sure we have a demilitarized zone
between Turkey and the Kurds the Kurds
were the allies who helped us defeat
Isis they lost 10,000 soldiers we've
lost eight and four years god bless the
eight but it was the Kurds who did most
of the fighting protect our NATO ally
turkey from elements of the Kurds that
they considered to be terrorists a
demilitarized zone occupied by
international forces no Americans but we
provide air power the president
appreciates what the Kurds have done he
wants to make sure Isis does not come
back I expect we will continue to
partner with the Kurds in the eastern
Syria to make sure Isis does not really
interest and we owe it to the Kurds so
he says more or less it's okay last week
he was saying this is the quote the most
screwed up decision I've ever seen this
week he's saying hmm maybe there's
actually a little bit to this he
actually goes on he tells Maria
Bartiromo who's interviewing him he's
actually increasingly optimistic that
this could turn out very well
the big thing for me is the oil fields
president Trump is thinking outside the
box I was so impressed with his thinking
about the oil not only are we going to
deny the oil fields falling into Raney
enhance I believe we're on the verge of
a joint venture between us and the
Syrian democratic forces who help
destroy Isis and keep them destroyed to
modernize the oil fields and make sure
they get the revenue not the Iranians
not Assad and it can help pay for our
small commitment in the future and
protecting Israel is a number-one
objective and we can do all of that with
a very small force increasingly
optimistic this could turn out very well
he's increasingly optimistic that is a
big change in tune what changed we'll
get to that in a second then we will get
to the greatest little fight I've seen
on Twitter in a while
tulsi gabbard versus Hillary Clinton
first I got to thank our friends over at
brickHouse are you eating all your
vegetables I know you're not if you're
anything like me your diet consists of
80% fatty Italian meats and 20%
provolone well you need to eat your
vegetables is a very important thing to
you ever wonder why Americans are so
sickly and unhealthy and lethargic and
overweight all the time it's because
they don't have balanced nutrition
between the food supply and our
sedentary lifestyle Americans are in
worse shape than ever and that is why
the team of on staff physicians at
brickHouse nutrition created field of
greens I really like field of greens
because it makes getting those nutrients
so easy field of greens is made with
real usda organic fruits and vegetables
it also helps boost your immunity using
antioxidants and it assists in digestive
health with prebiotics and probiotics
it's like having a doctor and a
nutritionist in your kitchen I like that
it's real food I don't want it to be
some weird crazy synthetic nonsense
that's like cooked up in a laboratory I
like that it's real and field of greens
is real one scoop delivers a full
serving of fruits and vegetables you
just drop in a cup of water you stir it
and you are done it's also great for
smoothies this is real food this is not
extract you'll look and feel better how
do you do it go to brick house Knowles
calm and get 15% off your first order I
get my own website that's how serious
these guys are brick house Knowles
dot-com you get 15% off your first order
and use the promo code Nolan Skinner
wles brick house smells calm promo code
no let's try it out you're gonna love it
this switch on syria lynn lindsey
graham's reaction is an important one
because it it shows that initial
reaction people buying into the sort of
madness anything Trump does is
considered unprecedented and terrible
and awful for our allies and
uninformed okay well sometimes that
happens but on this Syria decision on
most decisions what I try to do is I try
to take like ten breaths so something
happens Trump decides to move the troops
of Syria and everyone tells me this is
the worst decision in the history of the
world and we've never done anything
worse as a country and I say okay I
breathe in and out about ten times and
then I I think what's the alternative
let's see what the alternative is we
keep our troops in Syria but in that
region of Syria we only had 50 troops
which could be what's called a tripwire
it could be a way to keep hostile forces
out or it could be a magnet for an
attack as we saw in Beirut during the
Reagan administration after which what
did Ronald Reagan do he pulled our
troops out of Beirut if there were an
attack if one US soldier were killed in
that area especially if it were by
Turkey we could find ourselves in a very
terrible war do we want that war it's
not that Americans back down from a war
but what would what would the war before
what is our strategic interest in Syria
if you can't really identify one then
perhaps it's time to remove those troops
out is our interest to overthrow Bashar
Assad that's what people like John
McCain wanted us to do during the
intervention in 2014 in the first place
but we didn't do that that was never the
policy of the United States it is still
not the policy of the United States I
don't think it would be in our interests
to do it anyway so if we're not gonna
ask Bashar Assad then what is going to
give the Kurds a better long-term
strategy is it going to be to maintain
the state of constant civil war at a
certain point the civil wars got to end
or at least it's going to change is it
in the Kurds long-term interest to try
to create a nation-state as the United
States gonna get them a nation-state I
don't think that's very likely or are
they going to maintain this alliance
with the u.s. to the detriment of all
other alliance as well didn't work out
great for the Kurds in the 70s or the
90s or in the 2000s or in the 2010s
so maybe there actually is an interest
for the United States and redeploying
those troops maybe there is an interest
in the United States and backing the
second largest military NATO maybe the
situation is more complicated than it
seems maybe Trump is making a bad
decision but maybe that bad decision is
actually better than the other decisions
at his
special maybe maybe you think Trump is a
bad guy sure but it's certainly possible
he's better than the alternatives what
is the alternative you saw this not just
in the Republican Party in the
conservative movement you saw this among
the Democrats in the sweetest exchange
that I have seen since those 2016
debates in the general election Hillary
Clinton was on David Plouffe spod cast
talking about the 2020 Democratic
primary and she had the gall because
she's just like a broken record she has
to accuse her opponents of colluding
with Russia she accused tulsi gabbard of
being Russia's favorite candidate I'm
not making any predictions but I think
they've got their eye on somebody who's
currently in the Democratic primary and
are grooming her to be the third-party
candidate she's a favorite of the
Russians they have a bunch of sites and
BOTS and other ways of supporting her so
far now when asked if Clinton was
referring to congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard
Democrat of Hawaii Clinton spokesman
said quote if the nesting doll fits he
added quote if the Russian propaganda
machine both their state media and their
BOTS and troll operations is backing a
candidate aligned with her interests
that is just a reality it is not
speculation
so she's even confirming it she's
talking about Tulsi Gabbard everyone's
been going after Tulsi Gabbard because
Tulsi Gabbard is slightly more moderate
than the lunatics in the Democratic
Party and they're seeing a Democratic
Party turns slightly more in the way of
moderation right now because they know
they're gonna get blown out in the
general election otherwise how do you
think Tulsi Gabbard responded to Hillary
Clinton we will get to that in just a
second but first before we get to Tulsi
Gabbard before we get to the revenge of
the moderates before we get to national
period day we have got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube head on over to
daily wire.com what do you get you get
me you get the end replayed and show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get them at
wall show you have to ask questions in
the mailbag you get another Kingdom you
get backstage you get everything and you
get the leftist tears tumblr this is
very very important ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get
all that go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back with
so you have Hillary Clinton a crook a
twice failed presidential candidate
someone who's nearest contribution to
the American Public Service was lying
about being under Bosnian sniper fire
you have her and then you have Tulsi
Gabbard who I think is extreme and
leftist and I would never even consider
voting for her but she just returned
from serving our country in uniform she
is actually a dedicated public servant
and she's far more reasonable on most
issues than her fellow Democrats those
are the two people in Hillary Clinton
crooked Crone never did anything for
this country is accusing Tulsi Gabbard
actually put on a uniform of being a
Russian asset of being a traitor of
being somebody who sold out her country
here is Tulsa's response on Twitter
quote great Thank You Hillary Clinton
you the queen of warmongers embodiment
of corruption and personification of the
rot that has sickened the Democratic
Party for so long have finally come out
from behind the curtain from the day I
announced my candidacy there has been a
concerted campaign to destroy my
reputation we wondered who was behind it
and why now we know it was always you
through your proxies and powerful allies
in the corporate media and war machine
afraid of the threat I posed it's now
clear that this primary is between you
and me
don't cowardly hide behind your proxies
she misused cowardly which is an
adjective as an adverb that's okay we'll
forgive her because it's another wise
great tweet join the race directly oh oh
my goodness gracious I don't care what's
going on in the Middle East nothing
could possibly be fiery roar crueler or
more devastating than that very smart
for Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi Gabbard is going
to finally try to launch her candidacy
into the top tier by saying that she is
the chief antagonist to Hillary Clinton
in the way that Bernie Sanders was the
chief antagonist to Hillary Clinton in
2016 and it might work Tulsi had a very
good
at that last debate and so as the
front-runner Joe Biden falls apart and
as Hillary Clinton goes after her really
could help her out Hillary Clinton
seriously overestimates her significance
in the Democratic Party or rather I'll
put it a different way she seriously
underestimates how furious the Democrats
are at her not for her corruption not
for her decades and decades of Lies and
misdeeds for losing she lost to Donald
Trump she didn't get the job done and
Democrats are really hard on their
losing candidates when was the last time
we heard from Michael Dukakis do you
know program any of the listeners to
this podcast don't even know who Michael
Dukakis is Dukakis lost the election to
George Bush about Walter Mondale did we
hear a lot from Walter Mondale no George
McGovern not so much Democrats are
pretty hard on their losers and Hillary
Clinton thinks that she's somehow still
a important voice in the Democratic
Party she isn't really a lot of people
don't like her she went on that speaking
tour with Bill Clinton so she actually
had a former president with her they
couldn't sell tickets the tickets were
dropping from 300 hours a ticket then to
six dollars nine dollars a ticket they
ended up canceling most of the tour
why well we have another reason why I
add it to the list State Department
investigators have just concluded an
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
private email server and they found how
many security violations do you think
one or two and that's why it wasn't a
big deal but her email so it's not a big
deal
600 security violations that's according
to newly released government documents
600 security violations Hillary Clinton
not only using her own email server to
conduct very serious business of the
state but then destroying those emails
so she wouldn't have to turn them over
to investigators then we only found a
lot of those emails because they turned
up on convicted pedophile Anthony
Weiner's computer because her security
was so lacks
that his then-wife Huma Abedin her chief
aide was just letting her emails flow
around the whole house no big deal
why didn't the FBI charge her with a
crime well the reason the FBI didn't
charge her with a felony
at this point was because the FBI agent
who we now know was trying to undermine
the Trump campaign from within the FBI
Peter struck edited a key phrase that
dare buy removed legal ramifications for
Clinton the phrase was gross negligence
she was grossly negligent with her
emails at least and what Peter struck
did from the FBI was changed that phrase
to extremely careless let me ask you
what is the difference between gross
negligence and extreme carelessness
decades in an orange jumpsuit that's the
difference other than that they're
exactly the same phrase and and the
phrase extremely careless was obviously
cooked up to get Hillary Clinton out of
legal trouble people are sick of that
people really don't like that people are
willing to tolerate a lot of stuff to
get rid of that kind of corruption and
those kind of lies people are willing to
tolerate a brash billionaire from New
York who's never worked in the
government a day in his life who speaks
in a really rough manner
who does things and sends mean tweets
that a lot of Americans don't like
they're willing to tolerate that because
they are sick of the corruption they are
sick of this rotted out political
establishment Hillary Clinton obviously
is the sort of symbol of corruption in
American politics
but even guys like Mitt Romney and I'm
not suggesting Mitt Romney is corrupt
I'm saying he's dishonest I'm saying
he's slick used-car salesman I'm saying
he'll say whatever he needs you to say
to try to get your vote in whatever
election he's Ryan
and people are sick of that they don't
like that they like people to speak
directly they want to be told the truth
they know politicians are never gonna
tell them the truth
but if Trump is gonna tell you the truth
27 percent of the time instead of 7
percent of the time they're going to get
to him and they don't want radicalism
either I think this is what the
Democrats misunderstood about the 2016
election the 2016 election of President
Trump was
taking a guy warts-and-all because he
offered an alternative to a corrosive
political establishment
but it's not like the American people
suddenly became these crazy radicals
what the Democrats concluded is the the
Republicans became these crazy wild
radicals in the only way to win the
election in 2020s for us to become crazy
wild radicals nobody wants that
nobody wants national period day and
public celebrations of menstruation from
male politicians we'll get to that in
just one second they don't want that
they just want an alternative to the
political establishment
they might be getting that and we might
be seeing a vindication of my theory
here which is because at that last
debate I said this was Revenge of the
moderates this amount really moderates
but relative to the other Democrats
their moderates with Joe Biden's
campaign collapsing he was running in
the moderate lane he had a lock on that
that collapsing that opens up a lane for
some new candidate Pete Moo to judge
when he first started running for
president he was gonna be the kind of
moderate wholesome Midwestern guy except
he's really a big leftist but he's gonna
be nice and smile and make you feel good
about yourself then that wasn't working
so he started running far to the left
that was not a great idea he's now
running back toward moderation because
he sees an opening where Joe Biden was
and it's a paying off according to a
Suffolk University USA Today poll this
was conducted last Wednesday through
Friday right now in Iowa's is gonna be
first in the nation caucus state you've
got Joe Biden 18 percent
you've got Liz Warren at 15 percent
you've got Buddha judge at 13 percent so
he's still in third place that is way up
Buddha judge wasn't registering until
this last debate he wasn't on anybody's
radar now he's surged to number three in
the state and if the trend on Biden
keeps going down then he's within
within the distance of Elizabeth Warren
now that's only among 500 likely
Democratic caucus-goers but you know
there aren't that many people in Iowa
anyway so Pete Buddha judge having a
good time running as this sort of
moderate he's not the only one Amy
Klobuchar too is now staking her
campaign on being the moderate in the
race you're gonna see Buddha judge and
Klobuchar trying to grab that position
as a moderate because it sets them up in
a couple of ways this is still anybody's
Democratic primary all right there was a
there was a poll out of the Boston
Herald in New Hampshire that showed that
Warren Biden and Bernie are more or less
tied and actually the top candidate in
New Hampshire is someone who's not even
running yet Michelle Obama if Michelle
Obama runs she gets 26% Knicks candidate
gets 20 the next to get 15 that shows
you that the Democrats are unsatisfied
with the current crop of candidates so
what club you are muda Jed jerk it
banking on is hey there's maybe still a
slight chance that I could win this
thing but even if they don't even if a
leftist gets the nomination they could
be the moderate to balance at the ticket
so they're running pretty hard club you
char is running pretty hard by
contrasting herself with Elizabeth
Warren so Elizabeth Warren has these
pie-in-the-sky plans and she's not
willing to admit that the way she's
gonna pay for it is by raising taxes on
virtually everybody she has the same
plans as Bernie Sanders how do we know
she has the same plans cuz she stole
them from him Bernie Sanders at least
admits that everybody's taxes are gonna
go up Warren is refusing to do that
Klobuchar calling her out for it I've
made very clear how I'm gonna pay for
everything that I put out there I think
that's important because we've got a
president that's added trillions of
dollars to the debt on the shoulders of
our kids and I think we need to make the
case and as I said at the debate stage I
just think I have a better way a way
that will insure more people and bring
premiums down and that's with the
nonprofit non-profit public option and
it doesn't trash Obama care it builds on
Obama care and I think you have to show
how are you gonna pay for things that
bill has been very clear from the
beginning on page 8 it says that it will
dismantle our current insurance system
it says that 149 million people will be
kicked off their current insurance
that's what it says
and senator Sanders has been very honest
about that but I think we have to be
honest about that all the people in the
Senate that was on that stage and others
who said they supported it they signed
on to that I got a lot of pressure to
sign on to it I read it and I decided
there was a better way and a different
way to do it
have you ever heard a less inspiring
candidate in your life is she sober
voice or old man or old demeanor is so
uninspiring except what she's saying
here actually makes a lot of sense what
she's saying is
we need to pay for things we need to be
honest about how we're going to pay for
things we don't need to reinvent the
wheel every four to eight years we don't
need to completely scrap everything
we've done before us we can build on the
last healthcare system that we have and
then that health care system Obamacare
has been changed during the Trump era
and so we can work on those changes and
we can fix it up there is actually
something profoundly conservative in
what Amy Klobuchar is saying not really
in her policy outcomes but in her method
of addressing politics which is
evolution not revolution being somewhat
responsible and saying we're gonna pay
for it by raising taxes here and doing
this and I'm gonna find the money here
and we're not going to reinvent
civilization every four years we're
going to build on what we have
there's something very conservative
about that I have to tell you that it
kills me to say anything even remotely
complimentary about Amy Klobuchar or Pia
Buddha Jed or Tulsi Gabbard because
they're really awful I mean they are bad
they would make the country worse off
they would take away our freedoms they
would take away our money they would
further distort the culture they they
would not be good but they're so much
better than the alternatives in the
Democratic Party that I have to give
them a little credit where credit's due
I mean that's the thing with president
from today Trump I think is doing a very
good job I'm supportive of the guy
he's not without his flaws and he's not
without his mistakes and he's made
decisions that I disagree with some that
I strongly disagree with still politics
is about choices politics is about
choices and politics is about the real
world how do I know politics is about
choices that's the definition of
self-government in politics we the
people are presented with choices and we
choose one or the other we don't get
infinite choices we're not choosing
between things in the abstract we're not
choosing about things in the imaginary
world politics is about choosing things
in the real world it's not philosophy
it's not sitting around having a bull
session with your friends there are real
people all of whom are flawed and you've
got to make choices so what is the
alternative
the alternative to trump is Mitt Romney
if those are my choices I choose Trump
what is the alternative to club you are
Budaj edge and tulsi gabbard the
alternative is Kamala Harris the
alternative is Cory Booker the
alternative or who Leon Castro
so while Tulsi Gabbard was talking about
how it's not in our interest to be
fighting perpetual wars overseas where
we can't really define what victory
looks like while Amy Klobuchar was
saying we need to be able to pay for our
health care plans before we Institute
them what were those other candidates
Kamala and Booker and who Leon cast
we're talking about they were talking
about menstruation of course because it
was national period day the first-ever
national period day NPR explains it NPR
did a big cover on national period day
and the reason for it is according to
the NPR tweet quote on average people
who menstruate spend an estimated
hundred fifty million dollars a year
just on the sales tax for tampons and
pads now there's a push to outlaw the
so-called tampon tax across the u.s.
hash tag national period day this is
very funny for a few reasons one because
NPR presents itself as this very urbane
very sophisticated very literate outlet
and they reported that women on average
I'm sorry on average people who men
straight spend 150 million dollars a
year just on the sales tax for tampons
we must have a lot of billionaires in
this country if people are on average
spending 150 million dollars a year on
the sales tax for tampons gosh that must
mean they're spending a billion dollars
a year just on tampons on average now of
course they don't mean on average they
just don't really understand how numbers
or language work at NPR but the
illiteracy doesn't just stop there
because look at the term they use the
term they use isn't women spend an
estimated hundred fifty million dollars
a year it's people who men straight they
didn't even just say women who men
straight not taking into account younger
girls or women after menopause the
reason they say people are men straight
is because they bought into this gender
ideology and they think that men can men
straight that's
the alternative you know if my
alternatives if I'm a Democrat my
alternatives are tell us a gapper I
don't know if I love her foreign policy
entirely or Amy Klobuchar you know she's
got that voice and she's not you know
she just doesn't have a really inspiring
okay it's either that or people who
think that men can men straight I'm
gonna go with the first two that's a
troika mulheres tweets out one in four
teens have missed class because of lack
of access to period products that's
wrong it's time we end the stigma and
ensure everyone no matter their income
can reach their full potential period or
not hashtag national period day
now that that statistic is completely
made-up the rest of the period movement
which is what they're calling and said
that the number is one in five girls
have don't have access
teens who don't have access to tampons
haven't go into classism they're just
making it up they're citing a survey
from always brand this is what the left
does with statistics you know there's
lies damned lies and statistics they do
the same thing with campus sexual
assault they they initially said when
they pushed this campus sexual assault
epidemic that one in five women are
raped on colleges while they're there
and then while I was in college they
changed the number they said it was one
in four said wait hold on oh my goodness
gracious how on earth did it increase so
much since we were there what what what
sources are you studying they never
could tell you because they just make it
up it doesn't matter what the real
number is
and obviously it's not 1 in 4 or 1 in 5
that would make the campus of Harvard
University more dangerous than downtown
Fallujah all right there's no way that
that is true that elite Ivy League
universities are more dangerous for
women than Isis strongholds and I don't
know
Raqqa or something no that's not the
case they just say it because it's a
scare number and it makes you more
inclined to believe their campaigns cory
booker tweeted out quote too many people
don't have access to basic basic health
needs like menstrual products whether
due to lack of income incarceration or
gender identity so there is Booker
talking about how men can men straight
it's outrageous join the period movement
for national period day and support the
fight for menstrual equity menstrual
equity is what Booker is talking about
and then Ella wasn't really on caster
I'm sorry and this book wasn't really on
Castro who tweeted at the stupidest
thing about this it was Vado O'Rourke
who Leon Castro has regularly talked
about immense gynecological needs but
what Bay dough or work tweeted at is
quote in detention centers in prisons in
big cities and small towns women across
America don't have access to period
products they need a national period day
men need to join women and demanding
real change which is why I'm supporting
the menstrual Equity Act the
Churchill of our times ladies and
gentlemen they're addressing the real
problems you know whenever they do these
polls what matters to you the economy
foreign policy energy immigration always
at the top of the list is menstral
equity right no these guys are Jokers
and so when you're looking at the
Democratic primary you got to make a
choice
were you gonna pick obviously you're
going to choose the people who are more
sane than the other when you're looking
at politics generally who are you gonna
pick you're gonna pick a guy who's more
sane the guy who's more reasonable the
guy who's not blabbering about how men
need access to tampons for menstrual
equity day does that leave us perfect
candidates no does that mean we're
governed by angels
no the Federalist Papers already told us
we're not governed by angels we can
assail our president we can assail our
public servants is that worst possible
people in the world the question in
politics is what's the alternative
that's our show I'm Michael gnosis is
the Michael Doyle show I will see you
later I'm gonna be speaking tonight by
the way Kennesaw State University in
Georgia we are going to have a whole lot
of time as the men are not women tor
keeps rolling along around the country
then we're gonna be at the University of
Florida in a couple days so be sure to
check that out
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show up see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pawel wide
outski edited by Danny D'Amico audio is
mixed by Mike core Amina hair and makeup
is by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
you